I know are you gonna Jack you how was
your Star Wars Celebration experience it
was crazy it was it was it was mine you
know I I can only say like when before
we went on stage so nervous yeah a lot
of adrenaline going through and then to
come out and like be faced with all that
love and support and just like enjoyment
and excitement instantly felt at ease
this is fine yeah I can do this it's so
good yeah it's great we got to talk
about Jannah because you know I see her
is it it's @j a and then 8h yes okay so
I see her I see the yellow I see the
Cape I think in the same thing that was
asked on the panel yeah that looks like
a lando color scheme going on the yellow
and the Cape I mean look we're gonna
have months and months of speculation
yeah I can welcome to South welcome I
can only say that you will find out at
Christmas time okay all right she's been
she knows what she's doing okay let's
try this then three words to describe
Jana
what would you say fierce
okay cool fierce and strong now every
Star Wars actor has the I'm in a Star
Wars movie moment what was yours to be
honest with me there are many moments
because it's almost never fails to
surprise you and shock you with how big
it can be I guess my first day at work
first day on the job I was like this is
500 people like on set and many
different things that I can't tell you
about it wasn't very good it was so good
that I had to go away have quite a
little moment to myself
have a little happy cry mm-hmm and then
go back to work go back to work thank
you so much I'm so excited to see more
Jana
oh my god I'm sure people are already
planning their cosplay hello we cost you
[Music]